sur le site du musée pile elle vous avez
différents bâtiments dont fait partie l
hôpital d esclaves
un bâtiment qui a été construit au
xixème siècle vers les années 1830 par
les les propriétaires la famille des
bagues des bassins un bâton obligatoire
pour entrer dans le code noir 2723 tous
les propriétaires de plus de 25
esclave rêvé d'avoir un hôpital pour les
soigner d entretenir dans cet hôpital
dans la première pièce vous avez qu'on
appelle le mémorial c'est une liste est
cela qui a été recensée par madame
desbassyns en 1824 alors le mémorial
elle constituer le prénom d'âge et de
des fonctions des esclaves qui travaillé
sur l'habitation à l'époque dans parmi
les fonctions me citer la fonction de
domestique de noir leurs pioches de
nouara à talant
la première fonction parmi la population
de service était d'être demandeur est ce
qu a choisi par le maître en surveiller
toute une bande d'esclaves sur sur
l'habitation et le mémorial témoigne
rend hommage à tous ces esclaves à 290
et sans travailler sur l'habitation au
19e siècle
c'est prénom était grave et sérigraphié
sur de la sueur du de la pierre du
basalte et c'est l'association asud qui
a été chargé de le faire celui mangal en
96 alors il y a eu la restauration de ce
bâti en 1992 et là une opération
104 même si
moi